hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're going to be
continuing our study on the endgame
we're going to be looking at when you
should play for a draw so many times if
you were to study a GM game anytime they
go down any significant amount of
material 1 2 or even a whole point in
chess they just give up on the spot but
really if you're not a GM I highly
recommend you don't just give up I
highly recommend that you instead play
for a draw and so we're going to look at
a few instances that you should keep in
the back your head where you should be
thinking about playing for the draw even
if you have a losing game so in this
case if you look at right here in its
black Smoove
if black tries to move like Queen to d2
try and I down on this g2 Square trying
to checkmate the King as you can see
Black has a decisive advantage up an
entire piece this rook here on a - but
what black is missed and what a lot of
players miss is a perpetual check that
white can do perpetual check meaning
that white can continue to check and
check the King and there's nothing that
black can do to improve the game and
most players from that position just
agree upon the draw because the game is
going to go on forever just checking and
checking so from here black is missed
the move Queen to c8 he can't bring his
Queen back to d8 because then white can
just take on d8 and now black is going
to lose black doesn't want to lose this
game so he's going to have to move his
King from here the Queen can come down
to f5 and either the King can go back if
he moves his King back to g8 or h8
doesn't matter our Queen can now come
back to ca if instead he moves his King
to h7 and we move our Queen back to f5
let's try let's say he tries to move is
pawn to g6 now we can capture this pawn
on f7 and then the king and the Queen
are just going to continue to go back
and forth and this is perpetual check if
you perpetual check in the rule books
it's not a draw but most players after
perpetual check will just agree on a
draw and that's usually what happens but
as you can see here White's down a lot
and material by the same time black left
him an opportunity to
have perpetual check and especially this
happens if you have a queen any time you
have a queen I like to look for
perpetual check so many players if they
go down the material they try to just
throw the entire kitchen sink at your
opponent sacrificing pieces off the wall
trying for extravagant attack when
instead a lot of times if you go down
and you know you don't have a good
chance to win I try to set up a
perpetual trek I try to use the pieces
that I have to try to expose the king so
that I can perpetual check and use and
get a draw out of the game and I think
this is a lot more beneficial than just
throwing all your pieces away and then
losing the game pretty easy so we're
going to take a look at another example
of how perpetual check works in the
endgame in our next examples we can see
White has a huge advantage again up an
entire rook but if it's blacks move take
them in and see if you can find the
perpetual check and it's not that hard
but hopefully you came up with the Queen
to b4 and the king is going to have to
move one to place it's going to move
well three places a 2 a 1 or c1 but
either way the Queen can have perpetual
check B moves to a1 we can come to a 4
he comes back to b1 we can come to
before if he ever tries to come to c1
that we can bring our queen to a3 he
can't get out of these checks we can
continue to check him all day long and
there's no way that he can get out of
this so this is a simple way where if we
have a queen we should always be looking
especially for perpetual check if we're
down a lot of material where a lot of
players will try some fancy exchange and
end up losing the game pretty easily the
next thing I want to talk about is
stalemate and stalemate as we're going
to see can be one of the most effective
ways to tie game in the in game
still mate is a position where the king
cannot move but he's not in check and
this is a drawn game and a lot of people
don't win their games because they allow
their opponents King to be in stalemate
you know there's a lot of would be
looking to stalemate your own King in
this position here this is a famous game
where it's black smooth and black
thought it'd be wise to push his pawn up
the board
he saw that if pawn to b2 and the rook
captured on b2 then the rook had come to
h2 and after the King moved he could
take this rook on b2 and have an easy
endgame but what black did not see is
that after he came down to h2 the King
could come to f3 and after the rook
captures on b2 this is a drawn game this
is stalemate the King cannot move
anywhere but at the same time he's not
in check so this is a drawn game so
black had a decisive game winning but he
ended up drawing the game because of
stalemate so there's a lot of times in
chess we should look to stalemate your
own King so that you can draw and not
lose a game one of the things that you
want to look for especially is in the
King and pawn endgame and we'll go ahead
and take a look at that real quick in
the King and pawn endgame it's very
important to know when the stalemate can
occur and when one cannot occur in the
position if the pawn is on the F file or
the H file or if it's on the Bishop file
or the rook file however you want to
look at happens on both sides of the a
and the C of the F and the H if it's on
the F file or if it's on the H file then
this is going to be a drawn game if the
King can get to f8 or if the black King
can get to h8 these are going to be
drawn games there's nothing white can do
except to stalemate the black King so
these are a few things that you want to
look at if you're in an in game and you
can see that yes you're down upon and
your opponent may think he can promote
his pawn to a queen if his pawn is on
the F file or the H file or on the other
side on the a or the C file and you can
get your king to the eighth-ranked then
it's going to be a stalemate game
there's not
your opponent can do to win the game so
these are a few things one perpetual
check and to still Manning yourself if
you need to if you're down the material
if that's the only way to draw a game
it's much better than losing so these
are two things you could always always
think about in an end game hopefully you
guys enjoyed our third installment of
the in-game lessons if you haven't
already please subscribe thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next video